when talking about the world's 1.6
billion muslims
american presidents are traditionally
very careful to differentiate between
the vast majority who practice the
religion peacefully and the small
minority who don't
there's nothing in there in islam that
that condones the kind of brutality that
we've seen
our actions today were not aimed against
islam
the faith of hundreds of millions of
good
peace-loving people we are not at war
with islam
we are at war with people who have
perverted islam
president donald trump has not continued
this tradition
do you think islam is at war with the
west i think islam
hates us there's something there's
something there
that there's a tremendous hatred to
understand why trump is breaking with
his predecessors
you have to understand his chief
strategist steve bannon
[Music]
before he joined the trump campaign
bannon ran the far right website
breitbart where he hosted a daily radio
show
the second dumbest comment that one of
the dumbest presidents in the history
of these united states that would be
bush 43
shrub as they called him he made the
dumbest being that islam
is a religion of peace the face of
terror is not the true faith
of islam islam is peace islam is not a
religion of peace islam is a religion
if you listen to bannon's radio show and
watch his speeches you start to get a
sense of how he sees the world
bantam believes that the u.s and western
europe are in the middle of an
historical struggle against islam itself
[Music]
bannon isn't talking about the american
founding fathers he's talking about
european leaders who fought off muslim
conquests in the 8th and 16th centuries
that is the context in which bannon
approaches policy today
this context also helps us understand
bannon's views about refugees from the
muslim world
in a 2015 interview bannon and then
representative ryan zink of montana
discussed obama's plan to take in 10 000
refugees from syria
we need to put a stop on refugees until
we can vet why stop until we vet i
understand what do you mean vet why does
why not just why does why that's just
not why why why why why are you going
through all this thing on vetting
the opportunity cost of vetting well
betting's important because we don't
know
why no the only vet stop the commander
you only vet if you're going to let them
in why even let them in
to what end can't that money be used in
the united states i mean
i think the issue is should we just take
a pause and a hiatus for a number of
years
on any any influx from that area of the
world
bannon seems to think that syrian
refugees are incapable of adapting to
the american way of life
these are not jeffersonian democrats
these are not people with thousands of
years
of understanding democracy
in their dna coming up here right before
breitbart
bannon made documentary films in the
outline for one film which he didn't end
up making
bannon warns of an islamist takeover of
the united states
the opening scene features the call to
prayer and the star and crescent flying
over the u.s capitol building it's
pretty dark here in europe right now but
there's something actually much darker
and that is islam
though his current focus is on muslims
bannon has expressed a desire to keep
all foreign-born people out of the u.s
in a 2015 interview
he disagreed when donald trump said that
we should keep
high-skilled immigrants in the u.s you
know we have to keep our talented people
in this country
um i think you agree with that do you
agree well i i got a tougher you know
when two thirds or
three quarters of the ceos in silicon
valley are from south asia or from asia
i think
on on my point is that a country is more
like
sessions a country's more than an
economy we're a civic society
bannon is wrong less than 14 of silicon
valley ceos are asian
but the fake statistic supports his view
that legal immigrants
are just as problematic if not more than
those who are here illegally
isn't the beating heart of this problem
right now the real beating heart of it
of what we got to get sorted here is not
illegal immigration
as horrific as that is and it's horrific
don't we have a problem we've looked the
other way on this legal immigration
that's kind of overwhelmed the country
when you look and it's got 61 million
20 percent of the country is immigrants
the number is closer to 13
but bannon's point is that immigrants
somehow make
america less american he believes they
don't share american values and that
even when they're here legally
they take jobs away from native born
americans
and in this view bannon is way out of
sync with mainstream republicans
who along with business interests like
the chamber of commerce have long said
they welcome legal immigrants
we're going to need more legal
immigration immigrants are an economic
engine of vitality for our country they
make things happen
we need to figure out how to have more
legal immigration immigrants are the
lifeblood of our society i think
probably you know the most dedicated
americans are those who come here as
immigrants
bannon blames legal immigrants for what
he describes as a bleak economic
landscape for native born americans if
you're under 30 years old
your children are going to be poor and
your grandchildren
are going to be poppers the only way to
stop this from happening
bannon says is to rise up against those
whom he calls the ruling political class
those who allow immigration legal and
illegal to continue
think about it if the elites are so good
how did we get in this jam
this is the fourth great crisis in
american history we had the revolution
we had the civil war we had the great
depression of world war ii
this is the great fourth turning in
american history bannon's views have
already started to influence policy
multiple news atlas have confirmed that
he was behind the executive order
temporarily banning travelers from seven
majority muslim countries
and almost all refugees from entering
the u.s
a federal judge has temporarily halted
the ban but with the president's ear
and a seat on the national security
council bannon's vision of a closed
america
at war with islam will continue to
influence policy
you